president Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani
says mr. Trump will not talk to Special
Counsel Robert Muller before next
month's summit with North Korea
Giuliani tells CBS News the president's
legal team is tied up in international
issues and can't prepare for an
interview until after the meeting with
Kim Jong on Paula Reid is at the White
House Paula good morning good morning
president Trump's lawyers worry that if
the president was to sit down with
Special Counsel Robert Mahler it could
make him look more vulnerable than he
actually is they certainly don't want to
project any vulnerability ahead of such
a high-stakes negotiation Giuliani also
says that the president was so busy last
week with Iran and North Korea that his
lawyers barely had any time to talk with
him about the Special Counsel
investigation or engage him in any
preparation but the lawyers do hope to
make a final decision about whether the
president will even cooperate with
Special Counsel before the president
heads to Singapore for the summit and
Giuliani is of course a former federal
prosecutor and he believes an interview
could be risky for the president
especially if he cannot be sure the
special counsel investigators will be
fair to his client but the decision will
ultimately be up to president Trump Gail
all right Paula thank you very much